you wearing a gold chain alright yeah
I've had it for a while just gonna throw
it on every now man none of that is true
I definitely would have noticed a game
listen I've been working hard I make any
money for the first day I was like I'm
gonna sell something nice you know but
instead of that you bought a chain you
were just jealous I have a salary
quitter and you are too legit to quit
actor and comedian Kumail Nanjiani is
best known for playing software engineer
Dinesh on the HBO comedy Silicon Valley
he also co-wrote and starred in the big
sick it is one of the highest grossing
independent movies of the year with more
than 40 million dollars in domestic box
office sales the film is based on the
real-life courtship between Nanjiani and
his wife Emily Gordon it tells what
happened when Emily was in a medically
induced coma
forcing Kumail to deal with the crisis
with her parents part of the movie shows
him meeting his wife for the first time
after a stand-up routine my name is
Camille
now that the niceties are out of the way
I have to tell you that when you yelled
at me it really threw me off and you
really shouldn't have our comedians it's
so good
I didn't heckle you just woohoo to you
it's supportive okay that's a common
misconception yelling anything at a
comedian is considered heckling heckling
doesn't have to be negative so if I if I
yelled out like you're amazing in bed
that'd be heck oh yeah I'll be an
accurate heckle that's pretty good that
was pretty good actor comedian Camille
Nanjiani is here with us at the desk
welcome thank you thank you for having
me welcome so listen you got this idea
you had this idea of making your
relationship into a film but it really
started to take root when you were you
met Judd Apatow yeah it was his reaction
to the idea why he you know he basically
we'd hung out at a festival and he was
like oh I like you do you have any movie
ideas so I went in I'd prepared all
these ideas you know like those an idea
I had about a ghost which it's a bits of
which she dies comes back as a ghost we
don't need to get
but he was like okay do you have any
other idea and then I told you no I said
when my wife when my girlfriend I were
first dating she was in a coma for eight
days and I hung out with her parents and
he was like that's the movie we got to
do that because his whole thing is about
taking real true emotional stuff and
making it funny so that's that's where
it started because you wouldn't think
that would be funny why was she in a
coma she was just very tired you know
trip to Europe just she so I took her
took them a long time to diagnose her
she had this illness it was a mystery
illness and they couldn't figure out
what it was and her body was kind of
shutting down so they put her in a coma
to take stress off her body to put her
put her on a respirator and it took
eight days there have a name yeah it's
called adult-onset stills disease and
it's a very rare disease it was actually
on an episode of house oh that was like
the diagnose the crazy diagnosis he had
and everyone was like there's no way
it's that but that's what it was so then
you do work together on this film right
it's right here how did that work for
your relationship it actually was really
great for our relationship it's you know
people are like oh my god how did you
survive that it actually brought us
closer together because we hadn't
understood each other's perspectives
going through this event you sort of
think like oh we went through this
together kind of kind of it kind of not
really
you have your own because you know when
she wakes up in real life we're really
happy and she's miserable because she
doesn't know what happened she doesn't
remember the coma obviously so to her
she's like I was okay and suddenly I'm
hooked up hooked up to all these wires
and for us it was like yeah the worst is
over you know so it's interesting to go
through and really understand our
perspectives through this event talk
about the perspective of the parents cuz
I love this movie I thought it was so
simple yet it was so profound because
your parents Pakistani parents did not
want you to be with someone who wasn't
Pakistani and then her parents were sort
of looking at you like who is this guy
talk about the perspective the two
parents and how how that is today yeah
I'm
you know so my parents are Pakistanis
and they came here and and I completely
understand they wanted me to marry
someone within the community because you
know you want to protect your identity
and when you're in America any time
you're in a different country that
doesn't really value the culture you're
from it's always a struggle to hold on
to it right to hold on to who you are
yeah so that's what they wanted and and
it was it's different it was difficult
for them you know but now they really
love Emily and everything they want and
saw this movie many times I would see on
Twitter I would see people being like
after the movie this couple came up to
me and was like did you like the movie
Oh her parents thank you right away they
you know we were going through a very
difficult situation so it was kind of
that thing in the beginning where it's
like it doesn't even matter whether we
like each other or not we're just trying
to get everything yeah but in going
through this really intense couple weeks
together we really bonded because you're
sort of going through something that
only you you're the only three people
that can understand it you know yeah you
know one of the clips we showed earlier
too is joking about how Muslims are
portrayed in the media I know at a
recent interview you talked about that
yeah I think you know we don't really
have many different conceptions of
Muslims in American pop culture you see
them as you know in movies they're
always or TV shows are always planning
something so something bad yeah there's
something is being planned so Emily
actually had this idea there's a scene
in this movie where me and my where my
parents speak in or dude that's our
language and she was like I just want to
see a family speaking in order to and
have it not be like some sort of plan
they're coming up what something
sinister yeah yeah so this is there's a
scene in the movie where my family
speaks in Urdu and it's just they're
speaking in Urdu kids because that's
what they speak we just I think need in
this country just just need to spread
the idea that Muslims can be all kinds
of that's right people you know Emily is
the same brush how long have you and
Emily been together the movie actually
came out we didn't plan this but it came
out on our 10th wedding anniversary and
that was just a coincidence
I hope a ward only brings you something
to mail oh really great I hope so
mail Nanjiani if you haven't seen the
movie the big sick it's available right
now on Amazon Prime video you can get it
very easily